what's the libertarian solution to the
farm problem just free market free
market get the government out of it you
know under Ronald Reagan the subsidies
in 1980 where 10 billion dollars a year
they've got up to 26 billion dollars a
year and there's just as many
bankruptcies as ever prices are wildly
fluctuating as ever I think it'd be much
better if we got rid of all the
subsidies and gave the farmers steady
prices and a sound dollar low interest
rates prices it didn't jump all over the
place which is a reflection of the
dollar's value rather than just
commodity values obviously when there's
a drought prices are going to fluctuate
more than others but this whole idea
that when / farmers produce too much
we're supposed to subsidize them when
there's a drought and they produce too
little we're supposed to subsidize them
and now I hear there's a fost coming now
they're going to have to be bailed out
for the early frost you know first it's
over production there's a drought and
then there's an early frost I think the
idea is wrong I think it's bad economics
and morally it's it's wrong I mean I'm
having a bad year this year in medicine
I mean should I ask you to be taxed so
that you can send me some money because
I'm having a bad medical year or
somebody else has a business it doesn't
do well sure you can have sympathy that
he's your friend or relative you can
help him if you want but to be able to
coerce a non farmer to pay him because
he needs something or want something
violates all concept of Rights nobody
can demand something in call it a right
everybody has a right to their life in
our Liberty but they don't have a right
to somebody else's property and they
can't use the government to coerce in
order to get it if you became president
would you abolish the Federal Reserve or
try to and sits a constitutional
question also well and try to break the
power of the banking system in the
country we'd get rid of the Federal
Reserve but unfortunately it is a
constitutional question but it shouldn't
be the founders were rather clear they
say they authorized no central bank they
said we could not emit bills of credit
which is paper money they said the only
gold and silver could be legal tender
and the only monetary function that the
Congress had was to mint gold and silver
coins so if we'd follow the Constitution
we would not have a central bank of we
would not have a fiat paper currency we
would have a gold or silver standard or
both we believe that we should have
honest money which is a commodity
standard we don't believe in
counterfeiting we don't believe the
individual can counterfeit paper and
give it to people say this is money of
real value but we don't think the
politician and the Federal Reserve can
do that either we get rid of the Federal
Reserve and we think it would not only
help the economy what i would do is
would help the people because people
would save their money again prices
would be lower interest rates would be
lower and we'd eliminate the business
cycle so the sooner we get rid of the
Federal Reserve the better what would
you do about the deficit that's enormous
def adesso who had the deficit should be
eliminated by one technique cutting
spending you can't cut spending until we
decide as a people what we went from our
government we want welfare and warfare
the budget will never be balanced we're
gonna have an economic calamity is going
to be very very major if we want some
sense to our government we should
balance the budget we should do it
immediately and it should be done by
cutting and it should be cut both
domestically and internationally we
certainly can cut military spending
because a lot of the military spending
has nothing to do with national defense
we do not have to sacrifice defense I
believe we changed our policy we could
have a better defense but we would spend
a lot less money especially overseas
same way at home it's too much welfare
we cut back on welfare it's too much
interest on the national debt a sound
currency would lower the interest
payment so we would balance the budget
and media at a much lower level I think
it would be the greatest thing in the
world for the economy you have a last
statement you'd like to make for our
viewers yes I would like to suggest to
the viewers that you should look at your
choices i think this year you do have a
choice i think it's foolish to waste
your vote voting republican and voting
democrat is a pure waste of your vote so
if you want to vote for less government
if you want to say you're not satisfied
with the status quo then you have to
vote libertarian
if you stay at home which many people
are doing they're standing at home these
days because they are disgusted like we
are but they don't think as much worth
much chance of changing thing but if you
vote Republican or Democrat makes no
difference whatsoever if they like what
they have they're satisfied with the
status quo it doesn't matter but if you
don't want to waste your vote if you
want to make your vote productive make
your vote count come join the
libertarians vote libertarian send the
message because even if we get five or
ten or fifteen percent of the vote we
will revolutionize politics in this
country for the next hundred years and
that's what we want to do we want to set
the stage for the 1990s when the
Libertarian Party can be a predominant
force in this country